Hey youtubers it's Charlie and there is a
whole bunch of stuff happening for Korra right
now. There's a new trailer, Episodes start
airing next week and they're streaming everything
from Books 1 and 2 for free which means it's
Korra Marathon time.
I also wanted to announce that I'm going to
be doing a weekly giveaway in my Korra episode
videos. Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'm just going to make this video right here
the first one. I'll explain how it's going
to work at the end of this video.
Right now important stuff Book 3 Premiere
Date. Nick is dropping the first 3 episodes
next Friday June 27th at 4PM Eastern Time.
The first two episodes are a two parter called
A Breath of Fresh Air and Rebirth of a Nation.
That second episode is going to explain why
there are so many new airbenders popping up
everywhere. Hint Hint, harmonic convergence.
Episode 3 will air right after those, it's
called "The Earth Queen". She's the daughter
of the Earth King from Last Airbender and
her name is Hou-Ting. She's not super nice
and was heavily featured in those leaked episodes.
So if you watched those and you want to talk
about her in the comments. Please use spoiler
tags.
Here's some weirdness, as awesome as getting
three episodes at once is, there will be no
new episode the week after that. So they're
doing three episodes next week, then no episode
4th of July Weekend. It's an american holiday
for any international people saying WTF, and
then episode 4 will air July 11th.
Second big order of business. Nick is streaming
all the episodes from book 1 and book 2 on
their website Nick.com, so you can all catch
up if you missed book 2 or if you've never
watched the series before.
If you've never watched Korra before, trust
me. This is going to be the best new animated
show you watch all summer. There's only 13
episodes in Book 3, and each of them is only
a half and hour, so it's a very low time commitment.
It's going to be a Friday Night show, but
you can totally DVR it and make it a Saturday
morning cartoon show.
All the videos I make for each episode will
post a couple of hours after each one airs.
So you'll be able to watch them Friday Nights.
Now Here's a Breakdown of the New Footage
from that second Trailer
The opening scene sets up the post-Harmonic
Convergence world. Tenzin is a bit mysterious,
but when he talks about Change being good
or bad, he's referring to the effects Harmonic
Convergence had on the physical realm.
Because the spirit portals have been left
open and spirits are all over the place, the
spiritual alignment of the world changes significantly.
The bury the lead a little, but the reason
the Avatar exists is to serve as an intermediary
between the Spirit World and the Physical
Realm.
But what do you do when there is no more barrier
between those places. Do you even need an
Avatar anymore? That's going to be one of
the big stories of Book 3. What is Korra's
role in this new super balanced world.
All these spirit vines you see her calming
with the waterbending technique the dark avatar
taught her. I'm just going to call him that
instead of unalaq, just because it's cooler.
Those are going to be like homes for the spirits,
like places where they start to proliferate.
The reason Korra is trying to calm them is
because they're spirit vines, they seethe
with spiritual energy. Whenever things get
too crazy near them they start to go crazy.
So it looks like Korra is going to be patrolling
Republic City a little bit trying to help
learn about how their emotions can affect
the spirits.
The Republic City we saw in Book 1 and 2 is
heavily modernized with cars and mechs, part
of the Dark Avatar's mission was to crush
all that and give rise to a new spiritual
age where the spirit world dominated the physical
realm.
So most people will have no idea WTF is going
on or how to deal with the spirits.
The trailer cuts to a bunch of scenes of that
evil team of benders starting to break out
of their prisons. I think the spiritual realignment
in the world is going to heighten their powers
enough to allow them to escape. Otherwise
they probably would have broken out of their
white lotus prisons sooner.
The cut in this one scene of Korra frowning
while she's standing next to Bumi. It's not
chronological with these other trailer scenes,
those people behind her are probably new airbender
recruits that I'll explain in a sec.
We get a couple better shots of the evil benders,
The Airbender, The Earth Bender, The Water
Bender and The Firebender slash sparky sparky
boom girl. We haven't seen her use that power
in the trailers yet or the leaked episodes.
But don't be surprised if she does it when
she breaks out of her prison.
Zuko narrates a lot of the backstory for them.
They're basically four prodigy benders. The
firebender doesn't bend blue flame like Azula,
the most infamous prodigy bender aside from
the Dark Avatar, but I think it's safe to
say that when they're together as a team they
can kick Team Korra's butt. So part of her
journey in Book 3 will be finding a way to
defeat them that doesn't involve bending.
Here's that shot of shirtless Tenzin we saw
in the leaked trailer. Not sure why he's shirtless,
but I know some of you thought that was funny.
These Earthbenders that Asami and Korra are
battling are at the Desert Oasis. Remember
we saw a couple other scenes of Mako, Bolin,
Korra and Asami fleeing. Plus that evil earthbender
heating up all those rocks into lava. Either
the Oasis is where his prison was or something
else super shady is going on there.
Then we get full on confirmation of Bumi becoming
an Airbender. I'm so happy about this. It
was such a bummer that he was born of the
Avatar's lineage but didn't have bending abilities.
Bumi and Bolin will be where most of the comedy
flows from, it's a nice change of pace after
a season of people dying horribly on Game
of Thrones.
Here's the deal with all the airbenders. In
the description of the first episode it talks
about airbenders popping up randomly all over
the world. So Episode 2 is going to feature
Korra and Tenzin traveling around the world
trying to find them and bring them together.
Basically with the idea of rebuilding the
Airbending Nation. They've been almost extinct
since Aang's Time. dot dot dot. Last Airbender.
They talked about this idea a little in Book
2 in all the Tenzin Family scenes. Kya and
Bumi were a little resentful of Tenzin as
a child because he was the first new airbender
in the world so Aang took him everywhere with
him. And now there's hundreds of new airbenders
post-Harmonic Convergence.
Here's another couple of scenes involving
the Dai Li. Unless you've watched those leaked
episodes, their presence is a little mysterious.
But they're up to something really evil. If
you have seen those episodes and want to talk
about them, please use spoiler tags in case
people don't want to know the plot.
Here's a shot of Korra in the avatar state,
which makes me a little relieved. I saw a
lot of people speculating that she would be
unable to enter the Avatar State as a result
of what happened last year with the Dark Avatar
but I think it's safe to say she's just the
first in a New Line of Avatars.
And
that's pretty much it for new footage. I'm
really glad Nick is airing the season early
like everyone expected them too. There was
news going around this week that it was airing
in September on the Brazilian affiliate station
but they didn't say anything about when it
was airing everywhere else.
I don't necessarily agree with them dumping
episodes in clumps. It's a lot easier to process
new ones one at a time, but I'll take what
I can get.
Let me know what you're most excited to see
this season!
I can't wait to meet the Metal Bending Clan.
I've got my fingers crossed Bolin learns to
metal bend. We've already seen Korra doing
it in that last trailer. So it just be mean
if Bolin didn't learn too this year.
Here's the details on my Weekly Giveaway.
I'll pick someone randomly from the comments
on my episode videos. So because there's three
episodes next week there will be three different
winners. All you have to do to participate
is be a subscriber and leave a comment on
my episode videos. The giveaways are a way
to reward subscribers for being so awesome.
That's why it's only open to subscribers.
It's just my way of saying thank you.
It's an Amazon giftcard if you're in the US
and if you're international it's paypal. The
only rule is no assholes, I pick the winners
randomly, but after I pick someone I do check
all the comments they've ever left to see
if they have been super mean to me or other
people on my videos in the past.
So please remember this season to be nice
to everyone, it makes youtube so much more
fun when people are cool to each other.
Since they're streaming all of Book 1 and
2 on Nick's website my next bonus video will
post Monday or Tuesday and be a breakdown
of all the important things from those episodes
and how they're going to affect the plot in
Book 3. Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I'm also collecting questions for my next
Personal Q&A, so feel free to ask personal
questions on this video too.
Right now click here for my Book 3 Q&A and
click here for my breakdown of the first trailer.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!